- Hey kids, listen to me right now.
What you're gonna learn
in flipping right now
is gonna be foundational skillsets
that you'll be able to use in perpetuity.
And while everybody's judging you,
from your mom to your
grandma to your neighbor,
you're learning actual skills of survival
in actual life.
So tell them to go fuck themselves
when they're mad that
you got a B in science.
- Fuck you Ms. Guthrow.
- But you flip eighty four
pairs for $400 in profit,
see how small I said?
It's not about how much,
it's the skillset that you're gaining.
(intro music)
You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
Take care of yourself, stay well bro.
- [Male Voice] Be good.
Nice meeting you guys.
- You as well
- Do you book two or three?
(mumbles)
Just did a show on Complex about sneakers.
That was nice.
That's my outro, D.
I'm in operations mode,
I got a fucking company to run here,
I don't know if you've heard.
(indistinct chatter)
- Being twenty-six years old,
twenty-six.
Are you twenty-six years old?
Because if you are, I
just want to remind you
that I worked a cash register
in a liquor store in
New Jersey at your age.
Be patient.
(upbeat music)
- [Gary] Hot tip.
If you're meeting me for the first time
and you work for me,
blueberries is always a good strategy.
(hip hop music)
- Yeah, because when Gary
Vaynerchuk throws a party,
VaynerSports and 137 do not get
as much of a benefit as we want,
because everyone's like
you going to the Gary Vee party tonight?
People don't even know
who Gary Vaynerchuk is,
that's how crazy the brain works.
They're like, hey, I'm like hey.
I'm like, I'm Gary
Vaynerchuk, they're like cool.
And someone's like, you're Gary Vee!
They're like, you're Gary Vee?!
I'm like, you're looking at me!
I'm a human, you know what I look like!
And because I said Vaynerchuk,
you're still confused.
That's branding.
- Of course.
- And she's got some different turns,
so she didn't do the study abroad thing
and, you know, that's when
we went to Delray Beach,
when everybody went and was there.
She just wants to be a
little more family-oriented.
- Yup.
- Looking forward to coming back home.
- I get it.
- Not looking for an apartment outside.
- I get it. I lived at
home the first year,
yeah for the first nine months.
I wanna live with my parents now.
- That's what I said, I
was like I'm not leaving.
- I'm with you. I'm all about that.
- I think the biggest advantage
is the kitchen and cooking.
- Why the hell am I leaving?
And live in a shitty apartment?
I'm gonna stay here, take advantage of it.
- And they're fucking
thrilled to have you.
- Absolutely.
- That's awesome.
- You have agreed to sign
a bottle of wine for me.
I have a company that
produced a couple of products.
So these are toilet deodorizing tablets,
if you're familiar with the sprays,
so this is no-leak.
That's basically for
you and Team Gary Vee.
- There we go, beautiful.
- My man. Such a pleasure.
- So if I can,
so I'm almost on my 200th
episode in listening to podcasts,
you mentioned in Ask Gary Vee 299,
you were with Bilyeau,
you talked about taking 49% of companies
and running them through.
- Have you been doing investing?
Like you've made a lot of money.
- I have.
That's not as fun as it sounds, right?
- It's not.
- I'm kind of over it completely almost.
I wanna do some sort of incubator,
I don't wanna invest anymore,
I wanna find kids that, and old
people, I don't give a fuck,
people that have a three to
seven million dollar business
and I want them to give me 49% of it,
and then I wanna just plug it
in and make it do a hundred.
I think I can do that consistently.
- Could I interest you in doing that?
- Send me, the answer is
you're timing is incredible
because we're further
along in that internally.
You send me an email that says
I'm the guy that I just stopped by
all in the title,
in that 49%, in the body,
you need to give me context a little bit.
Where's the business at, top line file.
Just give me some context to decide
if we should get into a meeting.
Fair enough?
Pleasure.
- Talk to you soon.
- This is gonna throw a lot of people off,
I'm pumped to send my kids to college.
I just don't think it's required.
I need to watch them and
reverse engineer them
with my advice and let
them do their thing.
That's where I'm at.
- I think we're in a
shifting mindset on that now.
I think parents who have
little kids right now
are not going to be as pushy
about going to college.
Cause they're also gonna
understand the financial equation.
If you're a parent and you
have a little kid right now
and you recognize that
you've got fifteen years
about digging yourself
out of student debt,
you're not about to put your kid...
- Couldn't agree more,
couldn't agree more.
- Wait, let's talk about pantsing.
Who in this room, by show of
hands, knows what pantsing is?
- I mean, who doesn't?
- Well Sadam was in Turkey.
So, for anybody at home that doesn't,
how old are you?
- [Male voice] Twenty one.
- You don't know what pantsing is?
No he does. Which is why I asked him,
is I'm pumped that pantsing continues
because in this environment,
I'm not sure, like,
there were girls in my high school
that got pantsed in the
middle of the hallway.
- Like on some really
politically incorrect shit.
Let me just set the stage
as the old dog in the room.
When I was in high school,
the only thing guys
could wear were boxers,
like hardcore boxers,
like no other underwear was acceptable.
Not tighty-whities, not whatever,
boxer briefs, thank you.
Only thing acceptable was baggy boxers.
The amount of my friends,
thank God this never happened to me,
the amount of my friends that
got pantsed in the hallway,
and both shorts and boxers
went because of the nature.
like I feel like modern-day pantsing
because briefs or like other things,
everybody who got pantsed got naked.
Not you see their underwear, like naked.
- On some real shit,
Jesse Genet is one of my
favorite entrepreneurs
that I've ever met.
(upbeat music)
- Hey everybody, thank you so
much for scanning the bottle.
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk, one of the
cofounders of Empathy Wines.
- What's up?
- [Gary] Hello everyone.
I am well, how are you?
How's it going so far? Well?
Okay great, I'd love to go
around, introduce yourself,
where you're from and what you do.
And then we'll go back
around and do Q & A.
And I would make that very selfish
(mumbles)
You consume plenty of
macro free advice today,
I want to make sure that I deliver
on what you're singular
questions are here,
so let's go.
- We were. Yeah we were.
I started my company
in the conference room
of another company.
Like we were, like people
kind of continue to forget
that when you. Ground zero.
Got it. No. Respect.
We were small, for a long time
because the first two
years I was pretty passive.
I think when I took over
two and a half years in,
I think we were less than thirty.
- That's awesome.
- We got crazy when I
started running it full time.
I just love hiring people.
(laughter)
That's not a joke.
- [Male voice] So if you
could think back then...
- Couple core things:
disproportionate overcommunication
with every single person that's in it.
Like the game-changing reason
why VaynerMedia is still
foundationally strong,
is how close I was to the
first hundred employees.
It still permanates.
Said later that old Vayner, new,
there's many things that
will come from it later,
but it is the, honestly
it's raising a child.
Overlove the fuck out of your
kid in the first four years
and see ridiculous dividends later.
Like you know, later you
can worry about entitlement.
At four they can't be entitled.
Just love the fuck out of them.
Later you can not let them win.
You're the guy?
You have to build a real
relationship with all them.
Thanks for the post you posted yesterday.
It was very sweet.
You have to build a real relationship.
And you have to manage
all of them differently.
You have to manage them based on them,
not based on you.
At twelve and twenty,
like you're gonna have
that awesome culture.
Like people are gonna stay later,
you're close as fuck,
cut out the cancer quick.
If you by accident fucked
up and hired somebody,
you gotta get, give her or him,
the only time I'm pretty radical candor
is when they're a singular
cancer in a small group
where I'm like hey nobody likes you.
Well I'm the best employee.
I'm like cool, I'm still gonna fire you.
The best employee isn't the
one who makes the most money
or the client likes the best,
it's the holistic best,
and all eleven people in this office
don't love the way you're rolling.
So that's important,
early cancer's important
because it keeps positive vibes.
I think the first four years of a company
are disproportionately nurturing.
(upbeat music)
- Tyler.
- Yeah.
- Biggest misconception
of what's going on here.
- In life?
- Nope. In our world.
Hey Reed.
- That we're not focused.
- Ah. That we're focused
by our lack of focus,
or our chaos is our focus?
- That's exactly right.
- Good one.
- It actually creates a misconception
around a lack of focus
and strategic chaos.
- I love it.
- How's it going? Austin.
- Tyler.
- Hey Austin, Gary.
About to do the show.
(upbeat music)
- Yes, sir. Thank you brother.
- Real pleasure, how are you?
- And this is a good time for
me to give you guys these.
I got you guys.
Yes, we are. Yeah it was super quick.
Here's my thing, here's
my thing, thank you.
My big thing is that I
hope you guys flip it.
That would not hurt my,
because I grew up on baseball cards,
flipping at the US 1 Flea Market,
which we just referenced,
this is my core of my interests,
and so for me I don't
wanna be a hypocrite.
I lived my life going
and buying Shaq figures
at the Dollar Store and flipping them
at baseball card shows,
so even if my friends, if they flip it,
that makes me weirdly happy
because that's what they decided.
Thank you brother, thank you very much.
So yeah, I wouldn't have
any feelings towards that.
When I give, I give without expectation.
So if I'm giving you a pair of sneakers,
I'm giving it early
because you're my friends
and I want you to have it.
And if you decide that
the right move for you
is to flip it, then that makes me happy.
I'm being dead serious about that.
How are you?
You're in the calendar now,
this is probably like, this is, get ready.
People's complete misunderstanding
of how busy I actually am.